are you as ready as I am for Nicholas
Holt and Nicholas Cage in Renfield I
mean after hearing about what filming
was like for this movie I am so mad I
can't watch it right now Nick Holt had
to do everything for this movie I'm
talking about dramatic sequences bloody
fight scenes Hilarious Moments oh God
bless you none to spend a ton of time in
the makeup chair what proved to be the
most difficult was forging the
relationship with Dracula that had to
believably seem like it was centuries
old this came from a ton of rehearsal
time with the other Nicholas Nick Cage
the two built a rapport that they
described as something like a dance the
two had to be so in sync that they could
slow together with non-verbal
communication so when you watch the
movie keep your eye out for how the two
move together as a team now that's all
well and good but could I ask you to
like And subscribe real quick so I can
get to the main event Nick Cage no
offense Holt but everybody is going to
see this movie because Nick freaking
cage is playing playing Dracula turns
out the man himself is even more excited
about the part than we are too cage said
that there were three big roles he
wanted to play in his career they were
Superman Captain Nemo and Count Dracula
he very nearly got his wish with Kevin
Smith's Superman lives but had to settle
for voicing Superman in Teen Titans go
to the movies well it is important to
have dreams I guess no cage has a chance
to get another of the big three office
list and he's taking the job very
seriously I just think's coming threes
it's a good number as far as his
influences go there are the ones you'd
expect I'm talking about Bella Lugosi
Christopher Lee and even Gary Oldman
from Bram Stoker's Dracula directed by
Nick Cage's own Uncle Francis Ford
Coppola he even asked the famous
director what advice he would give about
playing Dracula Coppola apparently told
him that Dracula should be Handsome when
cage described his garish version of
Dracula like some kind of Picasso
painting Coppola said that didn't matter
this led cage to find what was glamorous
about his Dracula beneath all of that
white and blue makeup and those long
teeth it is what might surprise you is
Cage's biggest influence for playing
Dracula while he said that Christopher
Lee was his favorite the only right
answer by the way he wasn't the person
cage was channeling in his performance
Believe It or Not cage said his main
inspiration was his own father he was a
perfect model for Dracula okay so this
got me really excited because I love the
theory that Nick Cage has secretly been
a vampire this whole time while my first
reaction was Nick Cage is a vampire
confirmed the truth is that Cage's Dad
wasn't a bloodsucker or even all that
mean of a guy no what August Coppola the
brother of Francis Ford Coppola was
apparently an eloquent speaker with a
very distinctive Cadence the closest
you'll ever get to hearing August
himself is to hear Cage's Dracula and
that should tell you just how hard cage
went with his performance it's been
reported that cage went full method for
Renfield staying in character as Dracula
while shooting the whole thing I emailed
Nick Cage to ask if this meant he drank
the blood of humans to prepare but
strangely enough he did not email me
back while he may or may not have had
real humans for lunch every day the
makeup process was just as intense it
took three full hours to get cage into
the full get up not only that but it
required dental work he legit had his
teeth shaved down so that his 3D printed
teeth wouldn't affect the way he spoke
so put all this together and you have
one of the most iconic Dracula
performances of all time right well not
according to the man himself he said he
never felt like he fully got the
character down for the role though he
did say that he wanted another shot with
those fangs something tells me director
Chris McKay may be down for that too for
director Chris McKay this was quite the
passion project he and writer Robert
Kirkman yeah the Walking Dead's Robert
Kirkman were really excited about
entering this world from another
character's perspective and what you
might not know about the movie is that
it's actually a sequel oh yeah Chris
McKay actually intends this to be a
sequel to Todd Browning's famous Dracula
with Bella Lugosi you can actually see
it in the black and white scenes that
somewhat recreate the events of the
original movie though I've seen the
original and I don't remember it having
quite so many brutal fight scenes in it
so if you've seen the trailers you know
that Renfield has just a Sprinkle of
superhero style action on top of all
that vampire horror this proved to be a
unique challenge not just for Nicholas
Holt but for stunt coordinator Chris
Brewster and according to Brewster this
movie was the most fun thing ever
largely thanks to Chris McKay on most
films a guy like Brewster meets with the
director to see what the parameters of
the action scenes are basically finding
out how far is too far well there was no
too far for Chris McKay the only one
pumping the brakes seems to be Nicholas
hold himself you see while Renfield may
be able to eat an insect and then fight
like he's Quentin Tarantino's Spider-Man
Renfield himself is still a shy person
who doesn't love all the violence he had
to work with Brewster to make sure that
while Renfield was brutalizing people he
wasn't like Jason Bourne or other action
heroes honestly I would love to see that
conversation between Holt and Brewster
as they break down each scene beat by
beat to determine when Renfield should
feel bad about disarming someone
literally
Kevin feige I know you're working on a
blade movie right now well Nick Cage
wants to play Dracula again why not let
him fight mahershala Ali tell me that's
not a summer blockbuster
[Music]